now here I am in my vs code and I'm
looking at uh one of our functions which
is a database connection function that
connects our front-end website to our
backend product database it's written in
C plus plus and I'm going to migrate it
to go now in order to do that I open up
dual AI right from here within my vs
code I didn't have to switch any context
I type in my conversion question in a
natural language convert this function
to go and use cloud SQL now look at this
here
it knows the context it knows the
function here on the right is what I'm
talking about and there we have it it
converted an entire function from C plus
plus to go and not just that it also
understood that we had a basic postgres
connection to it to the date to our
database and now it converted that
postgres connection to a cloud SQL
database now this is Possible only
because dual AI is trained on Google
Cloud specific products and best
practices